المحاره مستفيدين يلعب ليلي ما شاء الله
تبارك الله بما مبلغ وقدره شاعر الاغنيه
ايضا
يستفيد بعض اللصوص عالميه وخمسين انا
توصل الى اعلى يعني
[موسيقى]
اخوك محمد فلاح
العمر 29 سنه مواليد الخبر
وافتخر اني من هذا الوطن العظيم
[موسيقى]
في ايام الدراسه خارج المملكه اول بدايات
الفاخر شكرا لكم للاهتمام بحالي يحييكم
ولا الحبيب الساخر اللي تركني في المكان
يعني بسيطه
[موسيقى]
ما اتوقع في مدارس شعريه وحاطينها وكذا بس
انا ما اعترف فيها صدق يعني انا على سبيل
المثال انا اكتب النص واكتب
الشعر ما اعرف فيه بحورة شي ولا اعرف يعني
ابدا اكتبه سبحان الله كذا يعني لو تسالني
في البحور وتناقشني بعضها ما اعرف اساميها
اعرفها كانك مثلا تجيب لي مثال على البحر
هذا وتبيني اكتب عليه اكتب عليه طبيب اسمك
تركيبته مفاعل ما اعرف ابشرها
[موسيقى]
فينا في امثله واجد ما ما ما عندهم في
العائله ولا شعر هو كان النابغه
حق العائله هذه او الاسره
والله شوف الموضوع هذا الموضوع هذا كبير
لكن انا من من الاشياء اللي خلتني انا ما
كنت يعني ملقي شعر بالي
كنت اكتب اغرد بعض الاحيان يعني ما هم من
اولوياتي لكن من الاشياء اللي حفزتني
كانوا يرسلولي بعض الاحيان يقولون ابوك
يكتب لك
فكانت يعني هم ياخذونها من باب
الانتقاد او التشكيك بس انا اخذها انا كنت
اخذها اني اذا انا زي ابوي لو يكتب النصوص
يعني لدرجه انه يكتب النص
فكنت اذا سمعت النقطه هذه
يجيني باور زياده اذا انا بجي ربعه بس ربع
موهبته خلاص
والله كتبت
قلت سلام منا الى ما لا نهايه
للي يحركها كلام
شاعر وعندي هوس مدري هواي اشوفها كل يوم
في منامي فيها من العقل واحساس الغوايه ما
يجعل الناس تبدا باتهامي احيانا اقول يبغى
لي قرايه لكن طيب ولا تبرد عظامي علمني
الوالد وصرفت فيهم بطلقه من حسام
[موسيقى]
من تجيك القصيده تميز هي زينه ولا شيء حتى
المتفوقين ترى متذوق الان او الجمهور الان
مو مثل الجمهور اول جمهور الان مطلع بشكل
ما تخيل
متثقف شعريه بشكل مال تخيله ما هو بسهل
انك تدخل عليهم باي نص انا عكس الكلام
اللي قلنا نزلت لا لا غير صحيح الدائقه
تطورت الجمهور صار يميز يعرف السمين من
الهزيل انا ضد الكلام هذا اللي يقولون انه
ذاك
بالعكس تطورت جدا الذات فيه احكم عليه من
فرنيات الفنيات القصيده من ناحيه تركيب
وقوافي او من ناحيه الموضوع نفسه الموضوع
قليل الادب باختصار
هذا
كون هجاء كون غزل فاحش انت اذا ما عندك
رادع ولا عندك ضوابط فعند سيئتي الحيوان
[موسيقى]
شوف
سبقا نتكلم فيها الشعراء الكبار الله في
عمرهم لما تجيك نعمه من الله سبحانه
وتعالى في خلف فضلها على الله سبحانه
وتعالى لا تقولي لا غير
اي موهوب في هالحياه لاعب الكره هل يجي
مارد يلعب معه من غير صحيح بس انه الطقوس
اكيد في طقوس معين بعض الناس يقول لك انا
افضل اني اسافر عشان اكتب نص افضل اني انا
اعزل افضل انا ما في طقوس معينه بس اغلبها
ممكن السفر
يعني اكون فوق السني مضبوط الشغله
[موسيقى]
هذي ما حد يجي يضربك على ايدك انت تجيب
قراراته نفسك وتدخل المسابقه تحمل وتجي
تدري من اللجنه
لا تفكك في اللجنه اذا انت جيت وسجلت
بعدين اذا كملت مراحلك تجيك انا دخلت
بقرار نفسك انت
لما تنتقل حتى في اي مجال اخر يعني انت
تبي تنتقد سهل انك انا اقدر انتقد
زميلي صديقي اقدر اقول ثوبك مو مضبوط اقدر
اقول اقدر احط فيه بحيث اني لما امدحه في
مستقيم اكثر واصعب علي
فالنقاط كثير الايام هذه واشوفها حبه
الايام هذه صايره هبش لانه مهما كان اذا
انت متعلم عندك دراسه عندك يعني في ناس
ممكن اسمع منها شخص ثاني ينفتح بث في تيك
توك وقاعد ينتقد ما خلى احد الا انتقده
وفي الاخير لما تبحث عنه تلقاه هو كان
يتمنى انه يكون شاعره
شعر المحاره مستفيدين يلعب ليلي ما شاء
الله تبارك الله بما مبلغ وقدره
الشاعر الاغنيه ايضا
يستفيد بعض النصوص عالميه
الفرقان بعضها توصل الى اول كان فيها
يعني محتكره على اسمها معينه
بحكم انهم هم اللي هم اللي في الصوره اما
الحين في زمن السوشيال ميديا انتم محتاجها
انت تقدم اللي عندك ويجونك يعني في اي
مجال قدم اللي عندك
لا تشل هم
عندي تماره بعد
[موسيقى]
انا لي بيت في ناس يقول ليت ما عندي مشاعر
ولا عندي قصيد كان انا اضيق ما احب صحبه
واخسر
كنت افضل اني ما اكون شاعر ايجابياتها
يعني يعرفونك الناس واللي مثلك وشرواك مثل
الزملاء بعضها يساعدك بانك تفضل بشكل اخر
[موسيقى]
اعذروني والله تراني في نص الرقابه